Thanks go then I accept full
responsibility first of all I want to
thank John Lindback for inviting me to
come speak here today because it got me
out of Dodge the folks from Washington
expect this morning talked about
reliving it and our stomachs return
churning we're still living at the
sarasota county and I'll get into that a
little while one of the first lessons
that everybody has learned and I thought
we knew that in Sarasota was to always
have backup so today I brought a CD I
brought a memory stick I brought my
laptop and after an hour and a half of
trying to make one of the work we
finally did get my laptop to do what it
was supposed to do so when I was
installed as president of the State
Association Terry Vaughn who is our past
president now introduced me as grace
under fire from everything that I've got
transpired in Sarasota County and today
even with my three backups I almost lost
my grace so I I really appreciate the
staff here or working with us Joe back
there was wonderful
and figuring out how we're going to make
this all work today so I'm sure today to
tell the Sarasota story lessons learned
in Florida and I'm supposed to talk
about security the DRDs and taper
balance you know halfway through this
whole thing what really dawned on me
Dylan talked about the fact that we had
a gubernatorial race in the 13th
congressional they also had a united
states senate race well katherine harris
happened to be the person who left the
13th congressional race JumpShip to run
to the United States Senate so my
impulse was to write her a letter and
tell her everything was her fault
because it she stayed in the 13th
congressional race we wouldn't have had
it in this whole situation
sarasota really is a beautiful summer
placement write you up I do have a
PowerPoint today when I spoke in Kansas
City at the election center I told them
sarasota county is going paperless we
don't really put anything in writing
anymore
think i'm kidding you we'll get to that
a little bit later too so I decided you
know we've got pictures we've got music
but not a whole lot of anything in
writing if anyone can hold against me